ويليام تشامبرج مرحبًا بكم في البرنامج، لقد
طلبت الولايات المتحدة المزيد من المساعدات،
ويحدث ذلك بشكل أسرع بكثير، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم أيها المسيحيون،
لقد كان هناك عدد قليل من الشاحنات
التي تمكنت من الدخول إلى غزة
عبر معبر رفح مع مصر أم
الدولي.  تمكنت لجنة الصليب الأيمن التابعة للجنة الدولية للصليب الأحمر
حتى الآن من
استقبال ست شاحنات محملة بالمساعدات الطبية الحيوية
والتي ستذهب إلى المستشفيات في
قطاع غزة بالإضافة إلى
فريق جراحي وصل أول من
أمس سيقوم بدعم المستشفيات
بالعمليات الجراحية العاجلة المطلوبة.  بالنسبة
للجرحى من الأسلحة، نأمل أن
يصل المزيد من الشاحنات غدًا وفي
الأيام المقبلة. بصراحة، يعد هذا بمثابة قطرة
في محيط مقارنة بما هو
مطلوب نظرًا للاحتياجات الإنسانية الهائلة
التي نتجت عن
الأعمال العدائية التي استمرت أسبوعين ونصف الأسبوع.
ويليام ش نحن ننظر إلى أه
الدمار الشامل في جنوب غزة،
الإسرائيليون مشهورون بأنهم قالوا للناس
انتقلوا من الشمال إلى الجنوب أنتم
في الجنوب ما هو الوضع
هناك في أي مكان اليوم في قطاع غزة
آمن نتحدث عن واحد من
أكثر المواقع كثافة سكانية على
وجه الأرض حيث يتجاوز عدد سكانها مليوني
فرد، كان هناك أمر صدر
تحذير للسكان المدنيين
في الشمال بالانتقال إلى الجنوب،
وقد تم الآن نقل آلاف الأسر ربما ما يصل إلى 300000 مدني
الحقيقة هي أن
الغارات الجوية مستمرة في جميع أنحاء القطاع
بما في ذلك رفح ونحن نفهم
أنه من الصعب جدًا التحقق من
التقارير التي تفيد بوجود تكثيف للأعمال
العدائية في شمال
قطاع غزة ولكن كما قلت أه الآن
نظرًا للقليل  مساحة كبيرة من الأرض وارتفاع عدد
السكان. بصراحة، لا يوجد مكان
آمن، هناك أعمال عدائية
في كل مكان وهناك
احتياجات إنسانية أينما نظرت. ويليام شانبيرج، لقد
انسحب العديد من
محادثتنا ونحن نجمعها معًا
أقول هذا لأن الإسرائيليين قطعوا الطريق
روابط الإنترنت والهاتف
أصرت الولايات المتحدة على إعادة الاتصال بها،
وهذا يعني أن الناس لا يستطيعون الوصول إلى
العائلات، ولا تستطيع سيارات الإسعاف الوصول إلى
المصابين، هل عادوا، أعني هل
أنت قادر بالفعل على العمل، هل
تستطيع المستشفيات القيام بذلك؟  سيارات الاسعاف
الاتصالات الهاتفية أه مقطوعة لأكثر من
24 ساعة مما يعني أن العائلات أه
غير قادرة على التواصل مع بعضها
البعض الجرحى غير قادرين على طلب
الدعم بسيارات الإسعاف والوكالات
الإنسانية غير قادرة على
العمل هناك الآن
عودة محدودة للاتصالات أنا قادر على
التحدث عبر الهاتف الإنترنت
لا يعمل في العديد من الأماكن
وقطاع GSA وأه القدرة على إدارة
عملية إنسانية في ظل
الظروف الحالية أمر معقد للغاية ومما يزيد من
التحدي حقيقة أننا  لم
يتمكنوا بعد من تأمين تدفق
السلع والأشخاص الذين هناك
حاجة ماسة إليهم حتى تتمكن
اللجنة الدولية والجهات الفاعلة الأخرى من تلبية
الاحتياجات العاجلة على الأرض.